as danny and cub columnist Donny okay
we're doing we do entire I'm doing the
wire whoa what is that you expect us to
remember all that seriously yeah okay
only due to 20 years all right now in my
piano
yeah skills but you can play rude
rudimentary just beneath rudimentary
whatever happens before you reach
rudimentary like you know we're middle
somewhere
how was Colin Farrell discovered side of
the road barefoot long walk to school in
the snow did Colin Farrell auditioned
for boy zone we have to talk about your
grammar first to begin with Boyzone and
I was tone-deaf I signed Careless
Whisper twice in a room for the
producers I think that got me down it
asked me to sing it the second time
because I was so tone deaf the first
time they couldn't actually believe I
had the balls to stand in front of them
and say so it was a boy band and look
great two of the members of the woman
had dead mics and I couldn't even be one
of them so that's how bad I was just
come for I have tattoos I have had I
have had I have I had I've been in the
process of laser removal cuz I might to
get an extra hour in bed in the morning
and I don't like to get me body spray
painted are you gonna get a tattoo means
probably you get a tattoo on your ass
you don't I mean this way you don't have
to worry about like when you view in the
movies unless you're me and then it's
definitely cuz I like to show my ass
okay let's go to the next night Ken
Danny DeVito can Danny DeVito I can
answer this with that sailor shirt yes
he can play the saxophone
only when somebody else is doing it for
me can Danny DeVito sing oh in the
shower
you know he's Danny DeVito leaving it's
always sunny no dude the Danny DeVito
play on the TV hit taxi Louie De Palma
who does Danny DeVito play in the
Simpsons uncle herb herb herb uncle
Horace who is Danny DeVito related to
you relate to me sometimes
Who am I related yeah is Colin Farrell
that's him I'm gonna rip this off it's
gonna feel like it's a bandaid on your
skin baby Wow it's conference holy can
you be listening to us accent to tell me
so it's a crazy loud mouth that's all we
had to do is spend three months
listening to that and you don't know
he's not the Brit okay what are you 23
and me DNA test someone to come out I
don't even 98.7% I are so close it's
tight Irish yeah here we go let's see is
Colin Farrell singing in crazy earth yes
absolutely any time you want them to
it's still there it exists yeah that was
me singing Ryan Bingham songs other
tunes thanks that was amazing thank you
it was very limited range in the song
which I where I could stay with it I
love shadow parameter is Colin Farrell
enjoying this game it's Colin Farrell
Voldemort I didn't think anyone knew
that we leave it there move on okay it's
come for her still alive I don't know
but I'll get right back to you I can't
wait all right I'm concerned our Colin
Farrell our car our coffin Fargo Robert
Colin Farrell our compound that's the
Baron Danny's playing the barrel here we
go yeah I know what a barrel is the
Irish right he's Irish
okay all right gone our Colin Farrell
and Will Farrell brothers yes we just
swapped out an e for an A so as to throw
people off
is Danny DeVito a blank canvas upon
which many people's ideas and feelings
can be painted it's Danny DeVito nice no
I mean I know people here nice and I go
that's a week or I want to be no good
Rob you are a nice not a nice sometimes
is Danny DeVito in DUMBO take your time
with this Ave and don't take your time
with this okay let's see yeah I am in
gumbo I play max Medici is Danny DeVito
in carwash walls not need to be too
uncommon what is link hi wash yeah what
you do in car wash Christine okay
machine just what right is Danny DeVito
drunk old times Danny DeVito Egan who is
Egan I mean vegan I'm sure there's a
video vegan are you of young man no
supposed to be ooh good passing
Wolverine what character oh what's his
name yeah Hugh Jackman yeah are you yeah
were you supposed to be Hugh Jackman it
was like Tulsa because of the ABS okay
is Danny DeVito and eagles house
do you support for the da I'm not it
yeah only when they're in the play and
you know that's Super Bowl of an Eagles
fan
yeah I mean I I'm like you know just
sunny in philadelphia but actually a New
Yorker so I root for the Giants what
what color a calm Farrell's eyes I don't
know like green yeah very nice I've
grown into my arsons give green eyes
he's got green eyes okay so first what
was calling liver oil for 42 years
well what was called first movie and
Frankie starlight as an extra in Frankie
star like thanks he didn't say anything
no words not a thing not a word giggles
in the background
uncomfortably good giggle now terrible
are you comfortable
okay what school did Colin Farrell go to
I went to a few I did the rounds yeah
who did I went to st. Bridgette's I got
booted out of the final it's in
Bridget's and then I went to cosmic
College when I was 12 and then I went to
Carmen's in boarding school from 14 to
16 and I went to Bruce College for one
year and then about three months into
the second year they said out get out I
just
the first that nuns no the first school
wasn't the first school was just a
flavor with her nuns involved it was
Vincentians
in the second school there was
Franciscans in the turrets go and then
it was laypeople in the fourth school -
schools of Catholic firstly thank you
they kick your ass the most yeah these
are what the nuns
did you waiting what yeah wicked what
book is Colin Farrell reading in Total
Recall - plastic Androids Dream of
sheeps some androids dream of sheep what
does that Philip a big book visit 200
plastic enjoy stream of sheep follow up
did calm your hands Dream of Electric
Sheep what languages that's Colin
Farrell speech Oh God tiny bit of Gaelic
cuz I'm Irish Danny oh yeah how are you
good I'm good
now I say I'm good Tommy come on salsa
means I'm pretty good like that you get
that one
okay here we go did Danny DeVito did
Danny DeVito ever won an Oscar No
nominated for Erin Brockovich but not
nice did Danny DeVito produced
pulp fiction here we go again yeah dude
did Danny DeVito write a book no are you
going
book you should write written in the
margins did Danny DeVito eat a real fish
in Batman absolutely no it was it was a
baby blue fish
how does call foul stay in shape by
having a healthy balance between copious
amounts of junk food and the odd bit of
stretching and work and hopefully okay I
can become famous Danny you know that
better working with me yeah okay here we
go let's go let's go to the next one
how tall is calm so that's without heels
flats how to get it Colin Farrell hair
coming to a pharmacy man how old cold
come a little comfortable is something
they're tired when to Danny DeVito agree
to do this area when Danny DeVito Danny
DeVito who played Batman when Danny
DeVito played penguin when is daddy to
view his birthday November 17 I'm 17
when did Danny DeVito die he when did
you die man they want to know when you
died why does Danny DeVito
narrator Mathilda why does Danny DeVito
narrator Mathilda thanks everyone
take care peace all the best okay